hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play gray we
are in the Attic
third floor type deal on smash things
with my pipe pointless it was a free
window right here oh we know yes yeah
there was a freedom window right here
why did I need to smash through that oh
this is the archives that's what he said
that thing that he said monthly plan the
plan this month is to renovate the third
floor fixing the wiring in the rooms
with heavy machinery is a priority
because everyone fixes wiring with heavy
machinery renovation of the flooring is
also urgent due to the movement of the
x-ray and other heavy machinery causing
tile damage to begin working on the
third floor all old documents from the
archives are going to be moved to the
basement level storage hazard we must
fix a hole in the storage room that
leads into the basement during our
moving all documents will be moved by
the staircase down while the storage
room is being worked on ok so there's a
tape that leads straight and lead
straight to the basement which I'm sure
will be spectacular for me
I'm sure it'll just be lots of laughs
fun times all around falling down the
giant because this what goes to the
basement is for flights down alright
well where is it
here it's already in here oh wait a
minute up it jacked up oh I thought I
had that oh I thought I had that I
thought it was like so smart
of course fixing something is covering
it up with a flimsy piece of plywood of
course ya know
I'm gonna find you jump throw yeah
whereas yo you can't hide from me
actually where is it gotta be right here
looking at the ground
they wouldn't SPECT they expect me to
look at the ground by a hold of the
floor in the ceiling makes total sense
I'm here
oh ah come on yeah here here come on
yeah oh come on why you gotta be this
way why you gotta make me look so stupid
in front a thousand of people yeah yeah
you you know yes God
Ganga nice where maybe this yeah okay
donk dink back dunk tank ah
well I suppose that's the end of the
let's play ah spent nice fun plane
having so much fun I just had a blast
being scared out of my mind hope you
guys did too
and I'll always know see ya there's got
to be they said right there there's a
freaking hole in the floor ah hole in
the storage room wait a minute wait a
minute oh I'm not in the storage room
ah I'm not in there oh that's it I
shoulda note before there is what oh I
know where that is
ah I'm an idiot I'm an idiot oh that's
why I couldn't break those boxes because
I needed to get back in here I'm an
idiot yes once again I've made myself
out to be the biggest city in front of
all of YouTube Hey okay moving on
going I know where I'm going now so I'm
getting a try
SCOR rum oh this looks lovely oh this
looks phenomenal
all right here we go oh
Austrade on the information blood a
mother leads me to the hospital where my
father had once been kept prisoner both
a body in of mind his madness as they
called it many could never live a normal
life again the asylum like hospital
looked down at me with menacing eyes it
had an air of desperation about it a
shared history of hundreds of lost souls
forcefully anchored to an uncaring rock
left slowly toward around left to slowly
drop Hey oh I don't like you
I should have jumped up on his bench I
shoot him the right off the bat but I
was in a bit of a panic okay good way to
start off a level transition great way
god I do not like those things fast and
they like take away half your help what
Duff Rika frak was that
what do I hear breathing seriously what
the heck what desi double hockey going
on around it they're giving me ammo
early stop breaking boxes it's quite a
few boxes I wasn't in a very smashing
smashing smashing oh boy I wasn't so
lazy Odin somehow Photoshop the face on
thing under the stairs yeah you stop
that right now Gabe you stop that I
swear ah God ah it's kind of cute in a
way but really disturbing it was his eye
Hey ah God totally no flash flash
lighted that guy it's almost like
noscoping ran efficiently anyway
moving on garage six-five go off oh no
oh I forgot I forgot the glide 206 ah I
do a three Oh what was it ah oh I forgot
I forgot
Oh sick 502 six oh my god no oh wow I
better remember that
oh damn it I don't even know if I can
get back how do I get back
ah he's so smart I'll be so smart I'll
load up one of my saves that I was there
oh I'm so smart
oh look how smart I am oh oh I'm so
smart
oh go tomorrow I don't have to go out I
don't have to cancel I don't have to
stop for Cory I'm not the smartest ever
I'll run orders ever just I'm the
smartest ever oh wait
I'm in the wrong place I'm in the wrong
place frak all right I gotta do it later
one just before the hospital basement
so right here good oh okay yeah right
here right here it's good hey it's good
this is a good place I like this place
it's nice you know homey
okay so the code is just down over
yonder way through here actually six
five four nine eight six nine six five
right if it's not six five I'm gonna
feel real stupid oh man I had and you're
all gonna think I'm the biggest idiot
because eat hi six five two oh six wait
up uh what I put in I put in five six
just wanna put in I put that in I put it
in six five two oh six maybe oh maybe I
need to put enter first
hey fry two oh six okay well then I'm
just an idiot
because this is obviously not the right
place for us I need to find another code
oh yeah I just wasted like two whole
minutes I'm so tired
so sorry but y'all must go on code in
here
I'm gonna remember 6 5 206 for as long
as I live probably hi oh no whoa hey
oh yeah gigging yeah [ __ ] you up oh oh
no no get back your dojo no you kid oh
ha don't like I know like I know like I
don't like that I don't I do not like
this I don't know why but this just
freaks me out
oh don't touch me oh I don't know why
really freaks me out like the most
disturbing thing I've ever seen
[Music]
there was nothing in here really no code
on the wall
nothing it's no wonder that wanted to
close this area off oh this area is your
breaking point this area cuz they're
really nothing what about that other
area I think Paranormal Activity closed
the place off okay
so here we go all right I'm on the other
side of the fence six five two oh six
I'm gonna remember that forever and ever
and ever
technically I remember did the first
time God God yes we're freakin what's up
you call over what do you think you are
boomer get out of here
oh I could look into the clock
[Music]
like this long hallway long hallway is
like perfect for a chase from a
souped-up chainsaw man without a
chainsaw
okay so what do I do here what's going
on here I do not like new leg don't like
don't like it all
you're not like I like it okay
perfectly normal that misses no no I
didn't miss it man that breathing needs
to shut up shut up breathing ah there's
a door over here wait no the fence is
gone
wait what the fence is gone what what
happened to the fence Oh
I don't like this I don't like this I
don't like this I don't like this I got
chills I don't like this I don't like
this is like a bad setup for a bad idea
bad everything is bad everything like
it's bad what was that something changed
[Music]
unserious got chills running up and down
my arms right now Oh everything about
this I don't I don't know what happened
over there with them
[Music]
gotta stop that man cuz anything besides
that is like really quiet breathing okay
alright so well there's nothing there's
nothing a lot of nothing
okay alright that's good I like nothing
nothing's better than something bad
daylight out there I'm like look with
people Papa okay all right uh I think
I'm all out of time for this episode so
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye